Britney Spears went viral this week for
uh all the wrong reasons which is the
only reason that she ever goes viral
anymore these days and of course she's
always you know she's always on
Instagram posting videos of herself
dancing half naked or fully naked
rambling
incoherently uh just coming off like a
very disturbed person she recently got
divorced from her husband after 12
seconds and he claimed that she abused
him I don't know if that's true or not
but we do know that she it was
definitely not the first time that
somebody close to her said that she is
volatile and dangerous this has been
what most of the people close to her
have been saying for a long time anyway
the video this week uh that went viral
Was Heard dancing with butcher knives
and she claims that the knives were
fake um they very much appear not to be
fake but here let's look at that video
for a
[Music]
second
the dogs in the background are
terrified there it
is I didn't even real I never actually
even watched the video so I didn't
realize that she was dancing what is
that Gregorian chant is that like
a somehow it's even
more disturbing than you originally
thought with the Gregorian chant in the
background while you've got this uh
half- naked woman dancing with butcher
knives and those knives are not fake by
the way those are not what fake knives
look like those are real so uh and the
cops didn't think that the the butcher
knives were fake either which is why
they showed up at her house for a
wellness
check um and they were the cops they
were not called by fans who were
concerned they were called apparently by
a friend of hers who was worried uh that
that you was worried about it and listen
it's all very sad um and it's even
sadder because we're watching this woman
fall apart in front of us and it it just
seems very likely that in the not too
distant future she's going to do
something drastic and really hurt
herself or
worse uh and it's like we all it's a
slow motion train wreck and we all know
that's going to happen I we all kind of
understand she's what in her early 40s
now the chance that she that Berney
Spears turns 50 seems to be pretty low
and it's like we all know
it so which is why her conservatorship
was in place to begin with
so once again um I was right and I said
back during the whole free Britney
movement you may recall and I got a lot
of flak for it a lot of
flak but I said at the time when
everybody was demanding that Britney
Spears be freed from her conservatorship
and why were they demanding it it's
because they saw some documentary on FX
or whatever and most of them didn't even
see the documentary they just they just
other people saw it and then it was
trending on Twitter #f freebrittany and
so a bunch of people jumped on the
bandwagon
and I said at the time okay people don't
get conservatorships placed on them for
no reason it doesn't happen use your
head stop following internet
Trends now none of us know even like 1%
of what goes on behind the scenes in
anybody else's life much less in Britney
Spears's life we don't know but we can
use our heads and we can figure out that
you don't lose legal rights to make
decisions over your own life for no
reason now of course everyone claimed
that it was a conspiracy by the people
who wanted Britney's
money okay
well once again use your head there are
a lot of of Rich uh celebrities out
there a lot of Rich female celebrities
out there who who probably have people
in their lives who covet their wealth
and yet they're not under
conservatorships Britney is why is
that could it be because Britney very
publicly had a mental breakdown and
repeatedly revealed herself to be a
danger to herself and those around her
including her children could that be it
I tried to explain this at the time
Britney a wealthy famous woman lost
custody and lost visitation right she
lost visitation rights and
custody um over her kids in a court in
Los
Angeles do you understand how difficult
that is to do you're a woman you're in
Los
Angeles and you're rich and
famous and you lose total custody over
your kids and you can't even visit
them do you know how how hard it is for
a woman to pull that off even if they're
not rich and
famous even even if they're not in a Los
Angeles
Court very very hard so you have to be a
monstrously terrible mother for that to
happen you just
do like is there a small chance that
it's all some big giant conspiracy
against you yeah I mean that's
anything's
possible but if you don't have any you
if you know nothing else about
someone but you know that they're a
woman who lost custody of their children
then that's you know 99.9% chance that
this is a ter this is like a a bad
mother doesn't even begin to describe
it and case we know about some of what
preceded that decision we know for
instance that she barricaded herself in
her home with with with her children she
had a standoff with emergency personnel
with her
kids reportedly she threatened to kill
herself in front of them we know about
that that was reported that happened
publicly okay if that kind of thing's
happening publicly do you think you
think it's better behind the scenes you
think you think what's happening
privately is less
disturbing there's a reason and her kids
don't want to be around her right now
again like you know if your if your kids
especially your sons as they get older
don't want to be around you as a
woman uh pretty good chance that you you
there's a reason for
that so you can look at these things and
you can use your damned head and you can
realize that obviously this woman is not
competent and and needs help or you can
believe a hashtag trend and a lot of
people chose the hashtag trend and now
This Woman's going to get herself killed
she's going to overdose something like
that she's going to end up dead and uh
and you know something if you were
screaming Free Britney then that's going
to be partly on you it just is and I
hope you're prepared for
that um it turns out that like just
joining mindlessly in some internet mob
there are real world implications to
that it's it's just not it's not
something you can just do like it's not
all fun in
games uh in whether the subject is
britty Spears or anybody
else when you jump on into an internet
mob without thinking straight you know
that that's it's not just I know people
like to say it's Twitter it's not the
real world no it's the real world this
is happening in the real world it's not
we're not dreaming
it and by the way I fully acknowledge
that this uh that this woman was screwed
up by all the fame from a young age not
just Fame but but a very obviously
sexualized kind of Fame I mean how old
was she when uh when Hit Me Baby One
More Time came out she was what like 16
or 17 or something and um all that is
terrible and her parents certainly never
should have allowed that much less
should they have facilitated it and and
pushed it as they did but the point is
that whatever the reasons for how she
turned out like this is who she is now
and you have to deal with who she is um
if she's incompetent and she's a danger
to herself and others then that that
doesn't become less the case or less
relevant just because there's a reason
why she ended up that way guess what
every every bad person every deranged
person every dangerous person every
crazy person every incompetent
person has a reason why they turned out
that way way you take anyone who falls
into any of those categories and you can
be pretty sure that their childhood
probably wasn't great like there's
probably stuff that happened to them you
know in the past that was pretty bad but
that doesn't change the reality of the
current situation we have to deal with
that reality before giving our dog rough
greens he was so sad and lazy now he
actually enjoys his squeaky toys and
playing Fetch with his frisbee our pups
days are filled with laughter exercise
and endless fun and so are mine
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of Ruff greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
little did I know before I got rough
greens dog food is dead food everybody
knows nutrition isn't Brown it's green
well let rough greens boost your dog
food back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so conf confident rough greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a jump start a
free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try it a free jump start trial bag
can be at your door in just a few
business days go to Ru greens.com mat or
call 844 ru700 that's rfffg greens.com
or call 844 Ru 700 today and also I have
to say that if a if a man is judged to
be a danger um to his own kids if he
barricades himself in his house with
them uh has a stand off and all of that
nobody is going to be saying that we
should be sympathetic because of how he
was raised like men lose custody in
court all the time they lose custody of
their CH of their children all the time
it's a lot easier to do if you're a man
and uh in many cases they lose custody
for bad reasons for illegitimate reasons
sometimes they lose custody for for for
good reasons um but you rarely hear
anyone giving a damn one way or another
about about their
upbringing so it doesn't usually work
that including also with with plenty of
dysfunctional you know celebrities out
there um who are who are whatever going
out and being self-destructive and all
that usually if it's a male celebrity
nobody says well think about how they
were raised think about that no one says
that everyone says like this person's a
lunatic so although we the The Narrative
is trying to make Britney Spears into
some sort of victim of the patriarchy
it's actually completely the opposite
you know if everything's exactly the
same with Britney Spears but she's a man
no no no one cares there's none of the
free Britney movement none of that
happens there's no documentary about it
nobody cares everyone just assumes uh
that she or he in that case you know is
is crazy and that would be the end of
it
so uh the only reason that Britney was
freed is because she's a woman uh which
which ultimately when she winds up dead
and the chances of that again are very
high
um you
know that's what taking down the
patriarchy gets you I suppose if You'
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed